i'm the friend who like to send y'all
to upstairs caz is a bad influence
film a very good time as long as yara
doesn't ask
i don't have anything to tell did he not
think she was gonna see this
or at least hear about it when the show
aired
come on joey the night before he and
yara were set to head to vegas for their
wedding
jovi went out to celebrate his bachelor
party at a strip club
cheers however before he left the house
to go celebrate
he made a few promises tiara that i
don't even think he tried
to keep we're having a good time i
probably should go back to make y'all
happy
but he didn't and now he has to feel
yara's raft which we know
that thing is pretty intense
i don't even hear your voice i feel like
i want to go back to your brain
yeah she's furious and in my opinion for
good reason
we're gonna talk about it plus stephanie
and harris are out here
confessing their feelings for one
another at the same time harris finally
shed some light
on where his relationship stands with
the mother of his kids
i have three kids we live 14 years
together with
my baby mother and everything our family
has ups and down
so sometimes she gets fed up with me so
she leave me
so that's the point i'm at right now his
response to what stephanie asked next
was even more revealing
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa
i hope you're doing well let's go ahead
and get into jovi and yara
who just can't seem to stay on the same
page for too long
when the episode first started they were
in a really good place
after having fight in our engagement
party joey been promised me that he will
change
and now our relationship better i want
to take a picture
[Music]
i got a million joby's been really good
to me
it's for sure make me feel better about
him
and i started to feel a little bit
better about staying in new orleans
kleiner yara is so funny but
they're such a cute couple when they're
nice to each other right
i've never seen them like that before
because you remember
at the beginning of the season yara was
mad
a lot and i mean a lot a lot
now we're starting to see her open up a
bit you know for a while she was
refusing to allow jovi's family to come
to their wedding
because her family wouldn't be there but
as she was dress shopping with jovi's
mom gwen she had a change of heart
you like it that's perfect i think this
is the dress which i want i will pick
this dress
great i like it and you're coming to the
wedding i don't know
i'm so happy that i found a wedding
dress
and that green was able to join me for a
dry shopping
and for the first time since i get here
is actually feel that i'm
getting married shortly after this
things started to take a turn
yara had this scary fall in the middle
of the street
which wasn't caught on camera but we did
see her and jovi coming out of urgent
care
and she clearly looked like she was in a
lot of pain
thankfully the baby was fine fast
forward to that night it is jovi's
bachelor party
and they're flying out to vegas early in
the morning for their wedding
before jovi went out he did seem
concerned about leaving yara
alone after her fall i would do whatever
you want if you tell me you don't want
me to go won't you want to go
so much i don't know a little bit i want
to go but i don't want anything i mean i
want you to be okay too
but now knowing how the episode ended
i'm not sure how concerned jovi really
was
either way she did tell me he can go out
as long as he follows a few rules
okay so i will go but not for a long
time
be an hour and a half maximum hour and a
half what you want me to do in an hour
and a half
yes two hours and a half you have
maximum to be home
okay we're making progress it went from
one hour and a half two hours to maximum
that's maximum
don't get drunk yeah i'm gonna get drunk
but i'm gonna probably i mean that's my
bachelor party of course i'm gonna have
a drink
class you can have i understand i will
drink but i will keep it
under control few drinks that's all yeah
because they've been on such good terms
and they're about to get married
i think yara really had hope that jovi
would
put her happiness first and listen even
if he thought the rules were ridiculous
obviously that didn't happen did you
already give you any rules
yeah she told me don't get too drunk
i forgot the other ones no motorboats
i'm definitely not going to remember
them if i do get too drunk
so no rules and make sure i can pack
maybe that was that one
no it's not you didn't pack yet not an
impact
we'll be leaving in like eight hours
yeah do y'all really think
joey forgot what she said i know those
hand grenades they're drinking are
strong
but the way he looked into the camera
right here
reminded me of when i was a kid and i
didn't want to tell my friends i had to
go home early
that's the vibe i got from this look
right here
how do you remember everything else but
the fact that she told you not to come
home late
that was the main part of the
conversation once he got along with the
producers
i guess they reminded him or he
magically remembered
this is my local hangout i used to come
here six or seven nights a week
and it feels good to be back but i
promised yara that it would be good that
i would go home early
who goes home at 11 o'clock what fun is
that for a bachelor party come on
jovi takes one step forward and
willingly
takes 10 steps back i have to tell
myself this
malicia when things are going good it is
not the time to think that you've earned
points
to do wrong that's how you mess up your
progress
girl i tell myself that all the time and
it's so true
plus his friend cass is not the best
influence
and i'm the friend like the sin y'all
too upstairs
still a very good time
[Music]
upstairs yeah yeah
[Music]
now you're forcing me you say whatever
you want
now does that go
[Music]
next week we're gonna see what time jovi
actually made it home
but whatever time it was based off of
the teaser
yara is pissed we're going to vegas to
get married and she won't even talk to
me
i don't even know what to think no one
even your voice
i feel like i want to go back to your
brain i understand exactly where she's
coming from
you want to be able to know that your
man is a man of his word
that's everything they're about to have
a family
and she can't even trust that jovi is
going to do what he says he's going to
do
i just wonder how he managed to come
back from this one
alright let me give you a quick update
on stephanie and harris
by the way she is still calling him ryan
you know what right or
you know what harris it's the fact that
she never apologizes
or says my bad for calling you that that
makes it
worse anyway stephanie
took time at dinner to make sure that
harris knows where her heart stands
i just want to let you know i've always
deep down had something for you
and it's not i don't want you to think
that i had revenge
sex and let's not revenge sex
you've always held a very special place
in my heart
i always wonder you know you you had you
know
baby mama pregnant when you were 17.
and you guys break up and then she goes
and lives with her parents
you know and then you get back together
with her what what's going on there
my kids i need to take care of them now
that is one thing one thing i've heard
from harris
that i can respect he prioritizes his
kids
that's probably why he's sitting at this
table right now harris went on to talk
about the relationship he has
with the mother of his children
revealing that they've lived together
for 14 years
and they've been on and off romantically
according to him
right now they're off you know we have
to take what harris says with a grain of
salt
but it was actually what he didn't say
when stephanie asked his next question
that said a lot does she feel like she
can't do better without me no problem
she find her next lover right i just
gonna say well no you want to move on i
just move on you move on and
let's move on she feels the same way are
you ready is that your choice no problem
right not gonna argue you have forced
you to love me because i'm forcing
someone to love me something bad because
then you're not gonna live happily
here it sounds like he might be a little
hurt by this woman
he completely glossed over stephanie's
question and started to talk about
not forcing someone to love him this
time around
stephanie did catch the drift and she
said she's going to keep what hair is
said in the back of her head for now
in the meantime let's take a look at
what we can expect from them
next week stephanie i want to tell you
something
i love you so much do you really mean
that
i have one more chance in my life okay
and harris might be the one
who told her she has one more chance the
psychic
she's only 52 plus there are people out
there who find love later in
life and i'm talking about real love not
whatever this is alright 90 day fans fam
to make sure you stay updated on all the
latest news coming out the 90 day
universe
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i will see you next time